[Music]
hi everybody thanks for uh for having me
here so I'm gonna talk today about
writing secure JavaScript code just a
little bit about me just for history is
that I come from kind of a a long time
security application security type of
experience through the Israeli army and
a bunch of application security
companies and then did about six years
in performance so for some people here I
know through that world and that kind of
back into a security startup dealing
with using open-source securely so kind
of jumping into it we all know I think
probably everybody here agrees that
javascript is awesome right you know we
all love it and we like to talk about
how javascript is one and it's the most
popular language and it's a kind of out
there by any metric kind of growing
faster than anything else and there's a
lot of reasons for it right there's a
lot of goodness in it and all sorts of
core javascript rates some are just sort
of scripting traits and some are
specific to JavaScript around you know
built-in memory management and native C
relation with JSON and the fact that
it's naturally scalable various sort of
great capabilities that help us be
productive right helps us runs run
faster and those are amazing
capabilities and their core right and
they are indeed parts of the reason that
javascript is is so successful and that
in general we can create these awesome
things but sometimes the same
capabilities that are sort of unique and
make it awesome also make it vulnerable
right so you look at these different
capabilities and you know while you
might see kind of built-in memory
management I would look for the flaws
there and I will see you know buffer
object kind of leaking memory from
server side if you talk about native
serialization attackers would look and
they would say well you can do some type
manipulation because types are decided
in runtime can I manipulate those can I
change so a lot of this talk today is
just going to be understanding a little
bit about how these capabilities can be
abused right how can attackers use them
to to understand the weaknesses in your
system and run forward the other thing
that's important to remember is that
these vulnerabilities in these types of
flaws don't just happen in your code
as part of a core a kind of a core part
of the javascript echo system our
packages are libraries then PME node you
know it doesn't matter if you use bower
if you use javascript libraries if you
just downloaded a jQuery away much and
much of your code is third-party code
open source code that you are using and
you know NPM is also awesome and as a
result its usage has exploded I'm kind
of picking on NPM but really this is
true for package management as a whole
and it has some like ridiculous number
of times and packages every time and
it's sort of updated slide and the
result is that a typical application now
will focus on node but this is
increasingly the pattern in in front and
javascript as well has a ton of
dependencies hundreds oftentimes
thousands one study put it at 350 on
average and it leads to the situation
where this is your app and this is your
code and and this may seem like a
negative slide but it's actually not
right you could create all that orange
value by just writing that little
purplish dot orangish value so it's a
good thing but it also is a risky one or
a slightly frightening one from a
security perspective it gives an
entirely different meaning to javascript
has one definitely on the dependency
metrics javascript is also leading the
charts so so with that context when you
think about security it's also
remembered to understand that most of
your app's code comes from NPM which
also means that most of your apps of
vulnerabilities come from NPM or come
from these packages so it's they're
different sources that can lead into
your system this is not a theoretical
problem it's practical roughly one in
seven when in eight packages in NPM
carries a known vulnerability doesn't
mean that 14% of them are vulnerable but
the packages themselves use other
packages that use other packages and
within that ecosystem roughly 14% would
bring in a vulnerability with them and
we see that pretty much every node shop
has those and this risks node apps and
this is kind of the focus that I talk
about here but when you talk about
JavaScript it's not limited to just node
it's also true for front-end application
with jQuery has a very prevalent
cross-site scripting vulnerability for
using a specific component of it you
know in react and angular in in with
browserify with all of these components
you pull in NPM packages and again the
same concepts apply for Bower
and it also risks the internet-of-things
so there's a lot of chatter today about
Mariah but all these like DDoS attacks
massive attacks that take down the
internet that are built on these devices
many of these devices run node apps or
very small lightweight apps and those
could have vulnerabilities so those are
that's kind of setting the stage and
most of the time not going to spend in
presentation but what we're gonna do is
we're going to try and combine those two
and what we'll do is we'll look at
real-world vulnerabilities in these NPM
packages it's I find it more useful than
fabricating an example these are real
packages with real vulnerabilities then
you may actually be using and has a bit
of a dual purpose one of it one aspect
of it is to see the vulnerabilities and
how can you kind of code to not have
them and on the other side understand a
little bit the security risks you might
be pulling in through those packages and
we're gonna focus on node but as I said
this is sort of applicable more broadly
so with that let me switch out of this
and introduce goof so this is a
JavaScript talk clearly it needs some
surprise I'm the first one to have a
model view control like I'm a VC app in
a JavaScript conference and it allows
you to do great things like you know
to-do lists say you know call mom and
you know it has some markdown supports
to emphasize important things and you
know just just sort of some features and
it uses a bunch of packages on it I'm
gonna use our tool snake it's on github
by the way and on snake slash goof and
you're welcome to clone this and play
with this after and run those expose
yourselves so we're gonna use snake to
to test this application to try and find
some of these vulnerabilities and I have
some pre opened tabs just in case it
doesn't play ball as we go so we will
test our different repositories and we
will find our little vulnerable app here
and we'll see that goof has a bunch of
these vulnerable dependencies so we're
gonna pick on that and expand and I will
kind of randomly choose a specific set
not randomly you know I've chosen a set
of these and show a bunch of exploits
and they're you know each of these there
would be some explanation that says if
this is a vulnerable package this is the
vulnerability on it and how it manifests
we're gonna start with this one with SD
who here is familiar with st not that
many it's a it's a package written by
Isaac from from NPM it's used to serve
static resources j/s and CSS and are are
website as well as our about page and it
serves static resources from the the /
public URL so to attack st st is
susceptible to a directory traversal
vulnerability and typically it would
read the the adviser here but you have
me so you don't need to see if this font
is big enough so what happens is you
know if we have some aliases to spare
instant typing but if we go on and we do
a curl and we fetch the about HTML page
we're switching to the to the terminal
because the browser has all sorts of
convenience features around
normalization and things like that that
kind of get in the way of attackers so
we can get the about page through here
as well and as an attacker if there's a
if I know where I suspect there's a
directory traversal attack then the
first thing I'm going to do is try to
break out of the static file folder this
is these are components that are
supposed to serve a set of static
resources but you don't want them to to
serve more than those resources so I
will put a dot dot slash dot dot slash
dot dot slash and if I do that I will
get nothing actually so if you kind of
scroll up you will see that I just got
redirected to the home page of it
because st is a smart package and it has
a security control on it it's not that
they didn't think about security
it just emitted something there's
another way that I can represent a dot
in a URL which is thoughts you're all
encoding so I can do % to e % to e % to
e % to E and that would get me all the
way up to the root and I can do as many
of those that I want and then I might
want to add some sensitive files say
like an et Cie passwd and voila I get
they D say passwd so okay so this is
just we're just getting started
simple simple vulnerability and and you
know sort of prevalence enough so we're
getting roomed up we're gonna go from
simple to complex right vulnerability at
its core the vulnerability that SD had
here and this is a common vulnerability
we see around is just not dealing with
encoding so you have to think about the
different ways that a character can get
represented in your system so this was
on the URL side so we show it a bit of a
URL encoding vulnerability but let's
look at another one in Marr
which is morning the HTML side so who
here is familiar with marked a few more
hands so marked is one of the more
popular marked down parsing libraries
out there and it's it gets about two
million downloads a month you know it's
it's quite prevalent and we use it to
sort of do that you know
emphasize beer and things like that in
our system now we know that it's
susceptible to a cross-site scripting
vulnerability so what's the first thing
we're gonna do yeah an alert script so
we're gonna try to do something like
this will say alert one slash script and
we'll try to do this because markdown
oftentimes many dispatchers including
marked actually support some HTML
snippets in there as well so we're gonna
do this and nothing we're just going to
get the text that's because marked has a
sanitize function in it now surprisingly
or not sanitize is actually turned off
by default so that's something to
consider many of these packages actually
have insecurity faults so they might
have a security feature might not be on
all the time but in this case we did
turn it on we wanted to be secure but
there are other ways to get a script
onto a page how else can I invoke a
script thoughts yeah I can do a link so
I can do there's a bunch of these I can
also do like attributes I can do a non
error I'm gonna focus on this right I
might do a script like this so this is
I'm still within markdown and I will do
an alert one and then what happens here
if I do this no nothing because mark
catches this and again the sanitize
function is quite comprehensive in fact
it is fully spec compliant so even if I
try to do get fancy here and I will try
to use an HTML entity so HTML entity is
kind of the HTML little sister version
of URL encoding or maybe the other way
around and I will represent this Colin
with ampersand in a hash and I think
it's a 51 and also from kind of past
experience I know that I also need to
encode this thing - I think of 40 so
cheat here a little bit oh sorry this is
41 and the other one needed to be 48 58
and these are just sort of ASCII
representation just numeric
representations of this character
and if I do this I'm now evading some of
the security controls and if I do this I
get
nothing so again like security controls
can be pretty tricky and this is on the
HTML side something that's important to
understand is mark is actually fully
Spector compliant and it catches these
things and there's no known exploits
that are not SPECT compliant but
browsers not so much
so browsers tend to be very tolerant
towards HTML mistakes and if I come here
say after this eight and I say I'm just
gonna zoom in further and I add the word
this
so the browser sort of season oh you
know you said an ampersand and you had
like the hash mark and had 58 it didn't
go all the way but I kind of know what
you mean you know I think I think you
mean a Colin and they would pull a call
in there and then the remainder of that
is just script and this is a valid thing
to call in script and I get a link here
and we got our alert
so vulnerability number two okay so kind
of first lesson from those components
you know one is just again think about
those think about the different
encodings and there's the URL side of it
and there's the HTML side of it let's
get fancier so in both of those cases
we've talked about encoding former
abilities but there are other properties
of all the JavaScript one of
JavaScript's kind of bigger claims to
fame is is that it's naturally scalable
right it is event-driven so it doesn't
require a thread for processing every
incoming request and it also means that
it's a bit of a point of fragility
because if one of those threads if there
is an action on the thread that makes
makes the thread take a long time some
algorithm some you know infinite loop
like the wild true that Jake showed
before right if you had the wrong
conditions you get those prompts in the
browser that says this script is you
know running for too long or you might
take down a thread on the server and
because JavaScript is naturally scalable
even high scale production systems have
a very relatively small number of
threads so it can quickly lead to a
denial of service vulnerabilities now
the most prevalent type of algorithm
that we run although we don't think
about it that way often is a regular
expression it's an algorithm it runs and
depending on how you write the algorithm
but almost always true to an extent the
the time it takes to calculator sort of
apply a regular expression is nonlinear
to the length of the input string
now that linearity may be hard or may be
low so depending on your regular
expression let me kind of switch back to
the slides a moment and show you a bit
of an example of this in a an aptly
named problem in regular expression
refer to as catastrophic backtracking so
you look at this regular expression and
it's it seems pretty simple right it's
just of ABCDE and you could have like
more of the C occurrences and then maybe
a wild card but what happens here is the
regular expressions are you know very
stubborn they try to match so if you
give them a pattern if you give them a
methodology where they can almost match
like almost get there but not quite they
will backtrack and they will try to
figure out another path and by having
nested groups like this so first if you
have multiple C's they could apply to
the C+ inside the group or they could
apply to the star outside the group and
that just creates a ridiculously large
set of possibilities and most regular
expression engines including the ones in
JavaScript will just try them all and as
a result you can see that by just having
this fairly short string there I don't
know that's like 30 ish characters I can
make calculating this reg s take a
second and then every character I add
would double that amount of time this is
on a sample machine but it's definitely
a lot of time so moment a very popular
package has recently had this
vulnerability I don't have an easy demo
on that one but another package that's
very popular that had it is M s and M s
is used for yeah M s is used for
calculating milliseconds or a timestamp
in milliseconds so we can say you know
call mom in two days and it would
calculate those two days to say you know
this is the number of time in
milliseconds so I can set a reminder so
and this has this vulnerability a little
bit less extremely so it also has a
regular expression now servicemen are
ability but it's not quite as extreme so
what we're going to do is first of all
we are going to again kind of make this
whole mom in 20 minutes and I'm going to
use HTTP or HTTP which is the same as a
curl just like with some syntax
highlighting and it goes on if I go back
to my application I will see that I
added a little bit of a record here but
what we will do is we will try to give
it an especially long string so and
again I'm just going to cheat because I
have it just to spare myself some timing
here and what we'll do here is we will
print 60,000 fives as the duration and
then we're gonna add another twist which
is we're gonna swap the last character
here instead of being an S to an a so it
almost matches but doesn't quite and
when I do this it takes a long time to
respond now takes a long time to respond
it's not a problem but the problem is
then the meantime my application here
isn't responsive so in this case I have
a single thread and this is just taking
out one heroku Dino here but you know
first of all you can hike up my bill and
if I add another zero you know it
wouldn't complete before the end of this
talk now this way it will I think in
about ten or fifteen seconds a complete
an end but this type of regular
expression in our service is a very
prevalent vulnerability and you have to
be very careful about regular
expressions both in your content and in
code overall and now in this case you
might say hey this is sixty thousand
characters who in their white right mind
would sort of past sixty thousand
characters but if it's not explicitly
blocked it is allowed there's nothing
really there the fix in MMS by the way
in the package is a little mediocre it
they just capped it I think it's like a
thousand or ten thousand characters the
the right solution is to have a logical
capita to allow twenty characters or
thirty characters in the different
sections so that you truly limit it
because otherwise it doesn't take down
the server but it takes a very long
amount of time to process okay so our
application will recover here we can
just kind of go back here and we deleted
a bunch of items so this was reduce and
it really comes back to the event loop
and the same times the problem can kind
of happen on front-end for my last trick
I will show a couple of other
vulnerabilities so this was an MS and
the last vulnerability I will show is in
Mongoose who here knows of Mongoose yeah
everybody so so Mongoose is know
everybody knows Mongoose is the way to
access money to be is kind of the top
one and it has an interesting
vulnerability
in that it tripped over an object called
buffer a buffer is a very very tricky
object in the world of note typically
when you wouldn't work in JavaScript
don't really think about memory
management right memory is this thing
that's just sort of handled for us but
buffer allows us to to play with a
little bit and to pre allocate some
memory and it has a couple of
constructors actually I went to the
advisory here but I can probably show
you here if I just do if I just run node
move this up a little bit so you can see
it and if I do I can do new buffer and
say 100 and I will get a buffer
allocated with those 3 characters 1 0 0
but if I do a new buffer and give it 100
I will get a hundred bytes in memory
that's intended however that memory is
not 0 as you can tell here if I do this
a few times you'll notice that you have
very different values in the different
items because this is just what happens
to be in memory and those 100 bytes that
I just allocated so as an attacker if I
can make the application allocate such
memory and then get access to that this
is a remote memory exposure and if I do
this enough times I basically can get
anything that's in the system's memory
including keys and source code and a lot
of those components this is like
heartbleed in open SSL except running in
the node process so only access to the
secrets that the node process has so
buffer has tripped up many popular
packages Mongoose included and for us we
we have a little bit of a simple schema
here that allows us to we use buffer as
the content field and you know so we can
have images and and other uploads and
buffering and Mongoose indeed had a
vulnerability where it did not enforce
the the right type that goes into the
component so what we're gonna do to
exploit this is first again we're going
to move to to the browser so we've
already seen that we can do a curl
command to invoke an item but what we
will do is our application like many
node applications also supports another
form of input which is Jason so I can do
echo with instead of a form field of
content adjacent parameter of content
and say fix the bike and if I do this
then if I go back to my application
I will see that we've indeed added an
item that says fix the bike but because
this is Jason I now have the ability to
modify it a little bit and instead of
saying fix the bike I can say 800 like
this which would give me 800 as a string
or because this is just naturally
serializable I can say 800 like this
when this gets si relized in the
application it allocates 800 bytes and
that memory is now a to-do item that's
exposed to me and if I look here I will
see just like a bunch of binary
components if I just do this enough then
you know it depends on the entry every
demo I get something different but you
might see some snippets of text and
source code kind of need to trust me
here that if you run this enough and you
do a loop you just sort of extract those
of course is an attacker you would kind
of clean up after you you would delete
these items right after so buffer has
dripped many items it's really not just
Mongoose but it's a pretty severe one
because it touches on memory and allows
that sort of be leaked out it also
demonstrates a general a broader problem
called a type manipulation which is true
for any kind of type dynamic typing
language and specifically JavaScript and
can happen with Jason but also can
happen in other components a good
example of that is Q s and Q s if I
parse a string like this I get a JSON
object or a JavaScript object with two
fields a and B but if I pass it to A's I
get an array and for instance this
tripped - KS which is a linked in
templating library that PayPal used and
actually had a real-world vulnerability
on PayPal because a sanitization logic
only happened on strings nobody
anticipated that an input that came
through the query string could be
anything but a string but with Q s it
can be with Jason it can be so it's just
something to be aware of to say do you
know which type is is the one that
you're using and just sort of as a last
anecdote is type manipulation can also
be used to do something called no sequel
injection so we've shown strings and
arrays but if you have something like
this where you use Mongoose to find
users by username and a password and
it's meant to be used like this where
you have an admin and a string however
if you can control adjacent input then
you can do something like this and
instead of a string in the password you
pass it among this function that
just say greater than nothing which is
everything which means that if you've
done this you just get basically like
SQL injection you get a no SQL injection
to return all the records and depending
on your application logic this might
have just made a pretty major thing so
so just to cap off I want to show you a
couple of things so before we close off
here one thing I do want to show you is
you know we talked about a bunch of
vulnerabilities that are clearly many
many more that we can talk about
hopefully these give you a tidbit and
the other thing you should talk about is
you know on one hand you should
understand the security flaws and on the
other hand you should understand this
application has been made vulnerable
without writing any of this vulnerable
code it just pulled it in externally so
you know a little bit of a shameless
plug you can try out snakes to help this
you know help find those issues you know
free for open source gonna try it out
and it would also help you fix those
issues just sort of open a fixed pool
request with a single click like magic
and just sort of try it out and take
over protect yourself going back here so
yeah as you sort of seen this live don't
start hacking website you know you could
get trampled in trouble and either way
it's impolite I will encourage you above
and beyond sort of general awareness to
you first of all think about the
JavaScript takeaways and these mistakes
and and how can you avoid them in your
own code and second is think about the
specific vulnerabilities in these NPM
packages use a tool like snake like no
security project there's a bunch of
these tools out there to help you find
those issues use tools to help you fix
those through upgrades through patches
through whatever means necessary don't
discount this this is a part of your job
this is a part of software part of
software quality these security concerns
so to recap you as an NPM are awesome
but please use responsibly
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]